first of all
you know i was telling you earlier when
i spoke to robert kennedy one of the
things i was very curious about was
the lineage in his family and what they
talked about at night
and what were the questions and how did
they get people to get mentally so
strong
and in one interview i think in the book
total recall arnold schwarzenegger talks
about the fact he met the kennedys
and he asked me to say so hey john tell
me what's your favorite color
and his answer was we like the color red
he says no but what's your color he says
no we like red he says
the kennedy seemed so united when i was
around them
when i read and study your family i mean
how does a family get folks to believe
for seven generations that we're all
going to be wire walkers so
if we can go back to where that
tradition the values and principles
who is the original founder that started
this tradition
take us from there and then we'll go to
all the different experiences that
you've had absolutely so my family
history dates back to the 1780s
so well over 200 years my family has
been wire walking
my great-grandfather is the one that
really made our family famous he brought
our family from germany
originally bohemia in the 1780s into
germany and brought our family over to
the united states
from germany in 1928 in fact he was
actually
performing and they were headlining on a
show in havana cuba and
they were making headlines around the
world for doing these amazing pyramids
on the wire
and john ringling the founder of
ringling brothers barnum bailey circus
heard
that he needed to see this amazing wire
troop so he made his way
over to cuba on a ship got off went to
see the show
and that evening my my grandparents were
great grandparents were getting ready to
get on the wire to perform
and as they got ready to perform the
show owner in cuba came up to them and
said this evening we're giving you the
night off
and my family sort of looked at
themselves and scratched their heads and
said this doesn't add up we're
headliners we're featured here
the audience this is a full house to see
us why are you giving us the night off
well the reason he was giving the night
off was because john ringling was in the
audience and he knew he was going to
lose this amazing performance group
to the united states and ringling
brothers circus but john ringling being
an astute businessman
snuck in the next day saw my family
perform and sign him to come over to the
united states to perform
on ringling brothers borrowing bailly
circus so they made their way over the
united states 1928
the the net the safety net that they had
used was lost in shipping and
they thought this is our debut in the us
there's no way we can avoid this we've
just got to go on without a safety net
and the story is told that they were set
up so high in madison square garden for
that opening night
that john ringling came into the arena
hours before the show
and said there's absolutely no way i'm
going to let them perform that high
and made them lower the rigging some but
the story goes that they got on the wire
and they did this amazing performance of
heart stopping feats and immediately
afterwards the audience went crazy
and they were whistling and screaming
and foot stomping but my family was
scared to death
because whistling and screaming and foot
stomping was the same as being booed off
the stage back in that time in europe
so they thought they were horrible they
were horrendous they were failures and
and that they were gonna get kicked out
of the country but little did they
realize the ring master ran to the door
and called them back to the arena where
they received a 15-minute standing
ovation
for their first performance in the in
the old garden uh so that's sort of the
legacy that i inherited but
my great-grandfather uh you know he said
it best he said life is on the wire
and everything else is just waiting and
for i think everybody in the world
especially with this virus we're facing
we're all on a wire
but for our family it's in the literal
sense life is on the wire that is where
we feel alive
my mom was six months pregnant and still
walking the wire that's crazy
i started walking a wire when i was 18
months old
it is truly life to us it is not a a
decision it is not a choice
it is it is truly who we are like the
kennedys like red
the wallenders are wire walkers